can an ice bath cure a hangover we've
created a facility to test the world's
greatest hangover chirps and we're gonna
test them on I'm dr. Keller wertham the
doctor of internal medicine I'm Frank
Krantz I'm not a doctor but I've been
hung over a lot
welcome to the GQ hangover lab telltale
is your name
for the folks at home through that book
likes I for walk it freaks me out when
you say cyborg why I don't know just a
child memory but yeah yeah he told me he
was a cyborg mom who said that guy
picked me up from school is that high on
my side because like cool he goes hop in
my spaceship all right this was your
night yeah I have a friend and she has a
party the rule is here's a beverage
there's a bathroom you have to come out
with empty beverage you have to drink
the whole bottle of oil and come out I
was drinking one quarter and then I
realized oh the bathroom has many holes
uh how are you just a little form like
strange sounds and then my brain I know
it's going a little slow if you have a
headache if this is my head and I go
like this that would hurt I don't I
don't it's pain we ran some tests we
checked your blood pressure your pulse
your urine which showed a little bit of
bilirubin meaning your livers in flames
this morning we did some cognitive
recall testing you're gonna repeat after
me
Golgi apparatus also called Golgi
complex or Golgi bodies it's not nice
now we have a cure for you today we
don't know necessarily if it's going to
work and we might learn why I don't know
this will be your uniform maybe things
will make more sense when you see the
cure okay ice bath that's the cure ice
bath cold water you know you've heard of
take a cold shower when you're hungover
there are a lot of these things called
prostaglandins in your system which are
inflammatory chemicals so it could help
reduce that and ice bath also channels
blood from the surface in the skin to
basically the vital organs so there's a
theory that that could help kind of
move more blood through the liver to be
detoxified faster Flula over here you
did it how are those fit those okay
that's covering some things it has been
suggested so we wanted to try it it's
the ice bag the ice bath and I think
we're gonna to really test it we're
going to need you to be in there for at
least five minutes three two
Wow got you there you go there you go go
ahead pit board on the chatter chest
part yeah I suppose I suppose more just
gonna giggles laughs I think that my Ln
in there it'd be easier if the whole
body was yeah put the legs up one leg up
there get going yeah yeah yeah that's
good that's gonna feel good splashes
made us its Glasson why don't we be
objective about this why don't we go
back and we'll make an assessment yeah
sound good okay what's the UM the worst
part of it put my penis penis and then
also my testicles your blood pressure
still okay right I assume your pulse Chi
rather than when you got in there so I
think we should do the cognitive testing
yeah if you're more alert alert okay the
test is to see how many words you can
retain last time you got nine words this
is a different sentence special
relativity implies a wide range of
consequences which have been
experimentally verified special
relativity implies a wide variety of
consequences which have been
experimentally verified and you know a
laboratories it's really cold ice baths
we don't really make tests we just throw
humans and really really [ __ ] cold
tubs and did we laugh at them and use a
timer
ha ha ha ha ha and then we take the
poise to see did it work I think we're
gonna stop there I feel like I'm being
mocked and you're mocking science right
now we had a we had a cure for you today
which actually does have you know of a
fair amount of some scientific basis
there you weren't as excited about it
imagine your testicles and penis of
football
sinn imagines this football is kicked
around for many hours and then a large
man sits on it and he is really cold
while two other men look at you and like
oh a little longer a little longer
what's wrong with you this is science
Flula did not like the ice bath cure but
I still stand by this just make sure
your bathtub is big enough for you full
submersion most immersion I give it a be
full submersion ice bath get to be a -
be nice I'm gonna give the ice bath I'm
gonna give it a see here's what I think
I think if the major thing that you need
is focus and to be alert the ice bath is
going to make you alert instantaneously
I'm dr. Keller weirdo I'm Fran Kranz
thanks for visiting the GQ hangover lab
for more tips and hangover cures
subscribe to the channel